plateau pour le décryptage
bonjour à l'ena une évacuation des
civils de l'usinage ostal serait donc en
cours actuellement il faut toujours
rester très très prudent avec les
informations qu'on donne de là bas
surtout que cela faisait près de deux
mois qu'elle était impossible ces
évacuations y compris hier la russie a
annoncé un cessez le feu l'armée
ukrainienne elle assuré que la russie
était en train de pilonner la ville de
quoi on est il exactement éclairez nous
alors pendant très longtemps il faut
comprendre que la russie a été jusqu'à
même nier la présence même de ces civils
dans ces souterrains de lusine asos
talent alors que pendant deux mois les
combattants du bataillon azoff qui y
sont retranchés diffuser ces images
qu'on a vu d'ailleurs dans ce sujet de
ces civils justement pour rappeler la
communauté internationale pour appeler
les ukrainiens et les russes a laissé
sortir ces femmes ces enfants ces
personnes malades qu'il était coincé
dans cet enfer bombardé pilonné en
permanence dans le noir en venant à
manquer de nourriture et c'est donc
pendant très longtemps la russie 10 et
le ministère russe de la défense me
disait soi-disant les civils d'après les
autorités de kiev coincé dans les
souterrains des obstacles donc remettant
vraiment en cause cette version puis
jusqu'au moment où c'est devenu
finalement impossible vladimir poutine
le 21 avril dernier a dit on arrête
l'assaut sur asos talent mais vous me
bloquer cette usine pour qu'une mouche
ne puisse pas volé c'était ses mots et
puis donc finalement en venir a annoncé
côté russe ces corridors humanitaires
pour rêver que ces civils mais là ça ne
marche pas jusqu'à hier ça ne marchait
pas là justement on disait qu'on était
prudent mais la rhétorique russe a
changé et désormais les rues ce qu'il
dit c'est que nous on met en place les
corridors humanitaires mais l'ukraine
les combattants ukrainiens eux utilisent
prennent les civils en otages les
utilisent comme boucliers humains alors
on va s'arrêter là on va regarder un
extrait de journal télévisé russe était
hier soir en prime time sur la chaîne
d'information rossi à 1 l'une des deux
principales chaînes d'information du
pays les 19 heures à paris 20h à moscou
bienvenue dans la réalité parallèle
voici les titres non mais ça bref voici
les principaux titres de ce jeu
[Musique]
mais personne centre eaton de nourriture
de rupture contrainte d'être humain
c'est l'arithmétique cannibale des
combattants d'azov et leurs prix pour
laisser sortir les cités de l'usiné
sauvetage tel drogue prennent les nazis
des nazis cannibales et drogué c'est en
tout cas c'est la propagande russe en
tout cas présentent les combattants etc
rien si oui est ce n'est pas une dérive
de langage c'est toute la construction
narrative de ce conflit en ukraine qui
justifie l'opération de dénazification
annoncé par vladimir poutine qui est de
dire que l'ukraine son gouvernement ses
combattants sont armés sont des nazis
alors on n'a pas ils ne le disent pas
seulement lorsqu'il s'agit du bataillon
à soft dont des éléments effectivement
revendique une idéologie néo nazis mais
tous les civils interrogé en tout cas
qui ont déjà été évacués de cette usine
à l'ostal remercie ses combattants de
les avoir protégés de l'avoir permis de
sortir etc mais vous l'avez entendu dans
cet extrait côté russe on parle de
cannibalisme parce que soi-disant
d'après des sources les combattants
auraient demandé à échanger les civils
contre de la nourriture
drogué ça c'est vraiment une rhétorique
on entend de façon générale et
permanente lorsque la russie parle du
côté ukrainien de ce conflit il faut
bien comprendre que dans son mythe la
russie est en train de rejouer la
seconde guerre mondiale et les deux
nouveaux aux yeux de l'opinion publique
russe dans une guerre contre les nazis
c'est ce que revendique delà des murs
poutine est donc là tous les moyens sont
bons y compris de parler de drogués de
cannibales de terroristes etc pour
désigner ceux qui combattent en ukraine
alors il semblerait bien que cette
évacuation de civils ce soit la dernière
étape avant l'assaut final qui permet
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'elle a été
annoncée par par le côté russe et
finalement on espère que cela aboutira
mais pour ce qui est des combattants en
tout cas qui sont retranchés c'est une
autre inquiétude pour ces civils parce
que nombreux sont ceux qui ont des
familles parmi ces combattants des
membres de leur famille et bien
apparemment le scénario qui se profile
c'est qu'il y aura un assaut final pour
finalement vraiment proclamer la prise
totale de marioupol qui a déjà été
proclamée par la russie mais manque ces
onze kilomètres carrés du sinn et pour
finalement on le disait aussi dans ce
reportage éventuellement tenir une
parade de la victoire le 9 mai sur les
ruines de marioupol assaut final qui
pourrait prendre du temps on voit
l'immensité du site lna oui alors
il semblerait que en main en parallèle
de l'évocation et c'est ce qui pourrait
éventuellement expliquer que le fait que
la trêve ne tient pas c'est que d'un
côté on essaie d'évacuer mais de l'autre
côté on continue cet assaut ce sont onze
kilomètres carrés ce sont des soutes des
kilomètres et des kilomètres de bunkers
souterrains hérité de l'époque de la
guerre froide qui ont permis aux civils
et aux combattants de se réfugier là
mais enfin atteindre et labyrinthes
c'est un labyrinthe mais apparemment les
combattants d'ukrainiens sont en très
mauvaises conditions ils ont beaucoup de
blessés ils sont exténués et il
semblerait en tout cas qu'il ne soit ils
vont devoir se rendre soit ils vont y
rester mais il y a de sérieux doutes
quant au fait qu'ils pourront résister
très longtemps sans aide extérieure ou
en tout cas très peu merci beaucoup
elena dans votre décryptage ce midi